and welcome along to this very special
BAFTA Q&A this the first one of these
that I've done and I'm very excited
about it even though I just quite like
to be in the same room as these people
we are virtually I'm sure Lords of you
are watching who have maybe been to
watch the entire series like I have of
the fabulous normal people and it is an
absolute pleasure to welcome to our
virtual Q&A room this evening the
director and the executive producer of
it mr. Lenny Brahma said hi Laney how
are you doing in here
lovely to be here thanks a lot and also
the the two leads from the show first
Daisy
Edgar Jones thank you so much for being
with us Daisy and pom pom ESCO and I
want to say first of all congratulations
how does it feel that it's out there now
[Laughter]
and listen just before we plow into I
just wanted to say to people that we do
have subtitles available for anybody who
might be watching we're also going to
open up to questions for you at home
wherever you may be watching in the
world so we'll do that at the end or
I'll start off selfishly and ask a few
questions but do get involved using the
Q&A function it's the best way to get
your questions and for these guys as
well and don't forget there's a double
bill tonight on BBC one at 9:00 o'clock
of episodes 1 & 2 and Lenny can I start
with you please because this is a book
that you kind of connected whether
release or founder find your own voice
and way back before it had even been
released the new yeah so um so I worked
very closely with a company called
element Pictures which is and a very
close friend that guy Nene it's his
company with Angelo and there's a sort
of gang of us in there they've been
working together for a long time and
normal people that had got ahold of
normal people before it was published I
think it was shared with I think it was
shared with a sort of a number of
possible producers with the idea that it
might be turned into something and I had
sent it to me or gave it to me and I
read it and yes I've I fell in love with
in the way that I suppose so many people
there just as a reader first and what I
was trying to think about the best way
to to describe that feeling but I think
for me it's it's two types of intimacy
it's the intimacy between the characters
and
selves and just how extraordinarily
that's portrayed and it's the feeling of
intimate connection you get as a reader
like this direct connection to the
actors no sorry to the characters and
for me that was very fresh and the
writing was so apparently direct and
simple but at the same time brings you
to these very deep places with the
characters and felt I just felt a
connection with them and a sense that I
could kind of see how it might make its
way onto screen which is the feeling you
need to have if you're going to
obviously gonna read out some yeah and
then at what point did did you kind of
make that decision that you were gonna
work on it and in particular Sally was
gonna be part of that as well you know
and and you know approach not about
being part of the screenwriting team as
well
what so the way it came about which
feels like it's sort of dream when I
think about it because it doesn't
normally happen like this if you know
but I was I loved it and myself and Ed
and the and the group talked about and
we felt that it was television rather
than a feature because it's very
episodic and I think there's lots of
things we can talk about there it's
really interesting why it works so well
as television maybe would be less
successful as a feature film but so we
went to BBC because we have this
relationship long time relation with
Rose gorynych who's had a film there and
even though television isn't her remit
she's just a brilliant creative force
within the BBC I'm very close to piers
Wenger who's the head of drama who we
also know and broader set brought this
proposition to them and they said they
greenlit us basically paid based on our
desire to do it and the novel itself and
that allows us to go to Sally and say if
um if you think we're the right people
to do it then we are going to leapfrog
all of the that that really sometimes
soul-destroying phase of development
that people watching this will be very
familiar with and we can we know we're
going to be making it in a year and that
I don't know just it also that gives a
huge injection of energy to the process
because um you're you're you are and
they were also supportive in the sense
they said whatever way you want to do it
whatever a number of episodes whatever
length of episodes um so I don't know
everything was just a part of the
creative process then
was no sort of process of auditioning
ideas or um you know it was just a
collaborative pretty open exchange of
ideas as we as we knew we were moving
towards an actual shoot day and then
when it came to to kind of that decision
on on how many episodes and stuff but
also how many you direct you've directed
half the seas and the fantastic happy
McDonald's done they're done the second
half and what was they what was the
reasoning behind that why did you want
to you know kind of in terms of direct
and half obviously being at across all
of it's an exec producer I did think
about for what I mean I did think on and
off about doing all of it but it because
we were on we decided we were going to
just go for it and do it and we had a
timeframe in mind which wouldn't have
been possible if I done all of them we'd
still be in post now if I'd shot all of
them um and also I felt like the story
does in a very subtle way fall apart and
fall into two halves in the second half
it's a slight terminal shift I mean it's
all part of the same world and the same
story and it flows beautifully but there
is that little shift and it felt then
that there might be a natural way of
breaking it into two and also having two
parts meant that we could attract a very
substantial directory like Hetty and
because it was really half-and-half it
wasn't like and you know it wasn't lots
of different pieces and and we were
delighted that she wanted to do it
because we love her work and she brought
an amazing sensibility to and within the
shape of the show and within the kind of
texture and tone of the show but still
very much her own thing and I still have
the pleasure of casting Daisy and Paul
and I'm setting it up and creating the
kind of fundamental kind of tone but
then it was odd and and definitely sort
of strange for me to hand it over but
ultimately a very rewarding kind of
collaboration and this might might sound
strange but you know when you read a
book and you kind of you visualize the
kind of characters in how they would be
in in real life and it was so weird
watch and you know I've seen the stills
and stuff but watching you two on screen
it was exactly who I had envisioned in
my head as
those characters it's really really
weird and I'm sure a lot of people who
feel the same I haven't you know for
those people who have watched it and
stuff were you familiar with it with the
story and the characters before being
involved in the project Daisy yes I I
mean I'd heard a p.m. of the story
because my one of my best friends had
bought it for my flatmate and might as
she is like a massive fan in fact she's
actually doing her dissertation on it
now so she's like I'm not very nervous
when she was watching it and actually
I'd sort of one of my friends that are
auditioned for for Marion as well in in
my house and I kind of remember
overhearing it and thinking well that
sounds quite good I hope that comes my
way but I saw it wasn't for another
month till I got the tape through but
yeah I mean I actually I sort of was
introduced to the book really from from
the audition process and and yeah and it
was an amazing thing to kind of read it
whilst auditioning because I saw I've
got myself tape and I sent it off and
and I really loved the character just
from from the little sides I got I
really thought she I you know I don't
know I found very funny and odd and
brilliant room so yeah reading it then
in between that and my chemistry with
Paul was quite an intense experience
because I was really sort of imagining I
guess myself trying to play her you know
yeah Paul what about for you yes is
similar enough in the sense that I'd
obviously heard about the book and it
was incredibly popular but am i that my
agent sent the auditions sites through
and I saw there was going to be based on
the novel okay that's the that's the
excuse I need to go and go out and read
the novel and I was doing a play at the
time in Dublin with a lot of a lot of my
friends who are else who I also know
been recast to normal people so we were
all kind of furiously reading through
the book and the thing that I remember
is that we all envision visit to
ourselves playing Carla which i think is
a testament to the two characters that
we all saw ourselves in that and then
i'm yes i read it before at the audition
process and then kind of kept going back
to it as the audition process lengthened
yeah and how would you describe each
other's character so Daisy how would you
describe Colonel and
or how would you describe my yarn that's
great question I love it
I play my favorite quote that I really
stuck out for me in the book is when
Maryann thinks of Conor was a big baby
tooth know how I love kind of to think
oh no he's just this very wholesome
special golden human being who is
incredibly kind of vulnerable and and
has a kind of really interesting
relationship with sort of I guess the
way he fits in in society and yeah so
I'd say big a big baby tooth oh how
would you describe my um it's so fun
because I watched it last night and I
kept saying when I was like part of me
from Carla's perspective I look at Mary
Ann sometimes and I don't see her as a
human being so I think she's incredibly
angelic in certain moments and unless
she has this wonderful ability to
forgive so I think she's in from Colin's
perspective she's a very forgiving
person
you know a character that has a massive
capacity to love and care and I think
she's also somebody who from Karl's
perspective is can be terrifying a time
yeah she is she's such a fascinating
character and really really
unpredictable I think is one of the
things I kind of love about about her as
well any for you when you were cast in
what what were you looking for and was
it an easy process and kind of what was
it about these - sorry that's about four
questions and one no no um I mean I
think you're looking for that feeling
that of conviction you know that you
believe the person in front of you and
that you but that you don't see there
you don't see the mechanics of the
performance peanuts you're looking for
great acting first of all and and then I
think you're looking for like it's a
combination of of just there's there
being something that chimes in the actor
and the character even if they're very
different people and just a feeling that
there is a kind of somehow they've
managed to connect with the character in
a in an organic kind of way
and then just a feeling it really is a
very for me Cassio is really a good
thing that you just think they've like
somebody starts and you feel my god
that's that's really interesting or
that's such a kind of that's the person
I can feel the presence of the character
and there isn't just one way of there's
no character for which it's just one way
of playing them there are lots of
interesting sort of nuances to different
people's takes but in the case of this
show when I saw both Daisy improve on
the occasions when I saw them and they
were very different times Paul came very
early in days it came quite late in the
process there was a feeling for me and
actually everybody else involved that
they were absolutely it that there was
just you know that you could breathe a
sigh of relief that we'd found the these
Caddy's actors who could really get
inside the characters and and then we
brought them together and with funny
when we were there was a bunch of us in
the room and we're doing this the so
called sort of chemistry reads and when
Daisy and Paul were together and I
looked around after they run a couple of
scenes and em three or four of the
people in the room were in tears so I
thought that's probably you know that's
just on a first read and with with the
two of them and it was all sort of there
at that point and then you know you've
got this I don't know there's alive
energy that feels correct for the book
and under the adaptation and and at that
point you can kind of go great because
it we can really make it now yeah
and these your accents fantastic and did
you have a muse did you have an Irish
music heard I mean actually then it was
like you should listen to Sally which I
really think was the best kind of
because she's from Mayo so she's from a
very similar place but um but she really
does just have this incredibly and
intelligent clear honest way of speaking
that I think what was really good for
Mariana and you know I had a pretty an
accent coach to whose name was Paul
different Paul I also listened to our
pool as well for a lot of obviously
living in Ireland she's helpful to kind
of get tuned in but my mom Irish as well
so I had had always had an idea
the sounds but yeah I'd say probably
Sonny was my my muse there's a there's a
there's so much truth in in this in
terms of the relationship that leads to
you know individuals have in the pool
that they have over a space of time you
know that they're it's kind of comes and
goes almost as waves in a way but in
terms of when you are trying to get to
that truth visually laney it was that
something that you spoke to both you
know your cinematographer but also with
with Sally and also Alice birch as well
in terms of of the characters and how
you were going to write this as a
screenplay to try and get that across
visually I mean it's always the
challenge you know when because people
will is a very like it's a it's a really
it's the challenge that you have when
you're doing anything for the screen
whether it's adapted or not in that how
do you represent the interior of a
person given that you're filming this
you know you're just looking at people's
outsides and you're hearing the voices
but so whether it's an adaptation not
that's always the challenge and then I
think it's just this combination of all
these decisions around the adaptation
itself and in that context I think what
I would often do is just encourage
taking things away you know leaving some
space trusting that so much of of
discovering something by observing it
versus being told it is always more
powerful on screen and just knowing
where that where that line is so that
you don't leave it so bare that it just
is impenetrable on the one hand but you
don't over describe or overstate or over
you know put things into dialogue too
much so keeping it the right sort of
bare and simple and then working with an
Alice and Sally and Market Road just
amazing in terms of their capacity to to
also respond to things that occurred in
rehearsal with Daisy and Paul and go
back to script when we discover
interesting ways through scenes and and
then um I worked brilliant brilliant
cinematographer called Susie LaBelle and
then has he worked with another great
Irish cinematographer called Kate the
color and certainly speaking about my
work with Susie it was just we watched
her a lot
we always you know as you do watch
references think about it but in the end
all you can do is sort of open yourself
up to what's happening between the
actors and try and find the most kind of
vivid way and simple for me wait for me
it's important that I don't appear to be
I don't want to be in the frame as the
filmmaker I wanted to look like we just
happen to be in the role yeah and he's
frozen we've frozen Lennie with frozen
him in time and I wanted to ask about
rehearsals with you too if that's all
right because I wanted to talk about how
important that side of it is for you
because you know one of the things with
this is that we're following these two
individuals through over us over you
know a long period time they grow as
people their relationship kind of grows
and you know one way or the other but
that rehearsal time how important is
that for you and kind of what did that
involve yes so am i I can't remember the
exact timeline of it but I remember
after me and Daisy had been cast
there was a slight bit of a hiatus and
then I think we did two weeks wasn't it
Daisy the guts are two weeks and we
didn't rehearse until I can credibly
rigorously it was kind of we would come
together for two or three hours and read
some of the kind of central scenes in
the piece and then we would just have
discussions and I think it was about us
there's two ladies their own place so we
would come and I think it was just
because we needed three of us to be
working so closely over the next couple
of months it was just about kind of
getting to know each other getting to
know what we thought about the
characters and how we worked it was it
was just a really gentle kind of Cree
felt very creative and I think that
energy is hiring us going into the first
week of shooting
what about few Daisy yeah I mean I think
like those two weeks I've never actually
rehearsed for anything before so every
was new to me and I I thought is amazing
to be able to kind of I guess first of
all get to know
call and any really well so that that
first day which is always terrifying
felt a little bit less like the first
day of school because you had a few
friends already which is done I think we
you know we didn't really I don't
remember really over rehearsing any
scenes I think what we did which I
thought was amazing was we really sat
and we talked really opened me for a
long time about all the kind of themes
and all the kind of moments that go
through the characters kind of go
through and and that was really
wonderful because you know the book is a
is amazing it you have so much you know
to go from but it's also some of the
characters and the choices they make are
quite hard to kind of get your head
around so it was really none I mean how
cool and to be able to kind of discuss
those so we always knew exactly what we
were trying to say with each scene and
did you guys spend much time just kind
of talking about the characters and you
know where that relationship was it's at
certain points and you know and why they
were making the decisions they were
making is that something that you walked
on with the two of you or mm between the
two guys together yeah it always felt
like that I think the three of us were
on very similar wavelengths and I think
that's how I think that's the reason of
both me and Daisy recast but I also
think that that's maybe what drew me and
Daisy to Lenny is the conversations I
like I remember in the second callback
which was the first time that I met
Lenny I think we spent more time talk
talking about the character not even in
the scenes that we were doing just just
cuz the like and one scene in isolation
especially with characters like this is
far less important than your concept on
who these people are so I think we I
just felt like we were all on the same
the same wavelength so the camera use
felt like collaborative it was really
lovely cuz when we went to the
read-through which was you know very
scary it was the first time we were kind
of meeting everyone Paul and I had done
you had to sub said the scenes out loud
and talked about them before so it was
kind of lovely whenever it got to scene
with us to we'd be like huh we know what
we're doing things out loud together
which was really nice you know before
starting to know that at least those
moments definitely
there or yeah there were definitely sort
of key scenes that we spent a lot of
time on and they became so touchstones
first for I don't know particularly
weight things that you sort the things
that would recur or sensual kind of
patterns in the relationship and we
would tie those down by working on sort
of central scenes across the episodes
and that but it is amazing how much work
you have to you read the novel that hits
you like a sort of a complete thing but
as soon as you start to break something
into the process of adaptation it feels
like you have to assemble it all again
and learn it like it from every possible
angle and the guys particularly I failed
to jump you know from one stage early in
the story to a stage three episodes
later maybe across the same day oh wow
being able to do that you just need to
know it so well at a kind of interior
level or you don't have to you know
think too hard but you can just step
into those different phases well I was
just about to ask whether you showed it
chronologically B obviously not then no
so the two blocks were effectively they
were a chronological in the sense that
we shot a block for the first six and
then has he shot a block for the second
six but within within the blocks we went
location to location because you know
unless you've the luxury of shooting a
scene upping the entire unit going
somewhere else and then coming back
three weeks later to that location you
what you end up doing is shooting at
each location so I think we started in
Maryann's tiger house and did everything
for the first six episodes that occurs
there and then we moved to another
representation it could have been
Trinity or it could have been school so
you're really I mean take a testament to
Daisy and Paul if you think about how
much they change yeah
like that when you see Daisy again in
Episode four how different she is when
you see poor the end of episode six
versus you know school boy it's pretty
amazing how that they can track those
and phases so accurately because there's
so many intricacies around those
developments as characters and people
it's not just yes there's physical
elements you know but there's also kind
of
emotional elements as well and that's
one thing that I think the you have done
so beautifully as well there are so many
really kind of hard subjects to cover
across these twelve episodes you know
mental health issues the the kind of
sexual you know sexual and behaviors of
people that kind of thing as well but
the way that you've confident you you
have to really think about the I guess
being really responsive to your actors
and and how comfortable and making them
feel safe but also in terms of the
subject matter and making sure that you
approach that and the right way with
with kind of yes authority but really in
a in a kind of thoughtful way as well um
it's it's a like it it is a very there's
lots of amazing stuff in in the novel
and I think we knew from the very
beginning that there were challenges you
know that that it is about a certain
kind of feeling of intimacy that 7 thing
I said drew me to it originally and that
that intimacy I think what we tried to
do is to just not differentiate really
between the scenes which were like in
which was component of physical intimacy
or once in which it was about you know
the characters are sitting opposite each
other like either end of a big room it's
all part of the same story and we just
what we wanted to do is represent the
truth of each moment as well as we could
and I think when you have that as your
as your guide it you know that you if
you stick to that you can't go very far
wrong because it does it there's a sort
of you know it's an honorable thing to
try and do which is just tell the true
to the story truthfully of what these
characters are feeling for each other
and it so happens in this relationship
that kind of that kind of connection is
felt across every aspect of themselves
emotionally physically you know
psychologically and and so um but we
were we were aware of how important it
was to get that right and to and to
maintain that sort of sense of I don't
know delicate watchfulness which is what
I think we talked about a lot in terms
of the style just that we would try
as as sensitive as you could to watch
what was happening and follow it as if
we were really desperate to discover the
sort of truth of the characters were
feeling at that time and I just noticed
somebody's asking if we can change the
view to M pic of you
yeah the so grid view is not it yeah but
I think that's another person watching
rather than us isn't that right I think
it is probably think it is no skin you
guys have to do it sorry yes does that
answer your question heed it yeah I know
it totally does and and just gone and
back to what you were will we talked
about before with dizzy and Paul and the
idea of you know you play these
characters over a certain number used
but the fact that in a day you may well
have to play that character over three
different time frames and stuff what's
in is that challenge or is that kind of
is that self is that an exciting part of
of the job and of playing these
characters how did you find that yeah I
mean I I definitely fact was very lucky
that um
Sharon and Sandra who did my hair and
makeup and Lorna who did the costume
were so wonderful at you know doing that
you know for me physically because I
think you know the clothes that you wear
in the way you style yourself you know
really make you feel different you know
so I think especially I remember the
first time kind of wearing this kind of
school uniform and feeling very young
young and that really helped but also
having the kind of having Lenny and and
Hetty to guide us was really useful you
know we always felt that you know with
Lenny we discussed the scene so we'd
always kind of and I guess ground
ourselves and kind of check in before we
were about to to lift off I guess you
could vote and then and also having the
book I mean it was so amazing having you
know your characters like so in depth
the way your character is feeling it
with each scene and you know what I
loved is is the fact that you know there
is sort of not much dialogue it is very
sparse and so you are alike and also the
way kind of Suzy films you know and
being very close meant that you were
allowed to just think the things and
feel the feelings and and then he would
kind of capture it and and that's very
freeing as an actor because you don't
have to force force for
project something you can kind of just I
guess just imagine it and think it and
and how do you prepare as actors for
those intimate scenes you know in terms
of Lennie very clearly talks in it you
know in advance to you about that and
about making sure you both feel safe and
comfortable with anything but with each
other how do you both kind of prepare
for that yourselves as actors I suppose
it's because it the process of doing
intimate scenes was brand new to me as
it was to Daisy so I think it was a
matter of like like during about two
weeks rehearsal that we had prior to
shooting we did a kind of trial day with
ether that would replicate a day on set
so suddenly you're not going to set on
the first day that you've to shoot those
scenes worrying about what the actual
mechanics of that day looks like so
anything that you can't control in
anything that production could control
in terms of making us feel comfortable
was put in place so then then you
suddenly you go to bed the night before
and you're you're thinking of the scene
rather than the event you know you could
because you know the structure is in
place you feel safe you feel comfortable
you feel listened to and then you try
and I think that's the beauty of the sex
scenes that are written in this is that
they are written as moments of
connection between two characters
they're not in my opinion or oddly
pornographic they're two characters
coming together who love each other so
it's about playing the scene rather than
playing the people do the sex scene
itself yeah yeah I'm sorry Daisy yeah
one lady if you go I was just gonna say
the other thing that was like the very
first time that they have sex we talked
about a lot the the desire to track the
scene from the two of them sitting down
and chatting in that in Connells tiny
bedroom and I'm not kind of break the
scene into two parts the preamble and
the lovemaking but actually watch that
the whole thing as one long encounter
you know and not think you know as if
the sort of the employed filmmakers are
not even aware that this is a sort of
we've stepped into some other realm it's
just a continuation of
of what's happening and so much of what
is so interesting about that scene is
what's happening in the characters faces
and in a way the nudity is is is it
allowed to be an incidental truth about
the encounter rather than the point of
the of any of the images yeah absolutely
Daisy what about for you just in terms
of that you know preparing and yeah I
mean I don't think anything can really
prepare you really for the surrealist of
what it is like on your first day you
know it is a different thing but as Paul
said I mean we were so lucky to have had
such a wonderful kind of experience
filming them and they you know they
ended up being a very positive thing and
and just like you know Lenny and Paul
said it's really refreshing to be able
to I guess experience them as any other
dialogue scene you know they don't feel
any different and and you know I love
that episode to you seeing because you
can see those two people kind of
carrying on communicating it just
becomes physical and and it just meant
that you were able to act it you know
you didn't have to feel self-conscious
so I'm for having ether and having such
a lovely crew who really looked after us
and made us feel safe and it just meant
that the pressure was removed and so by
the end it's funny as human beings you
get very very used to something that
initially is one of awfully surreal by
the end you kind of you didn't even
think you it was just another okay so so
that was wonderful that that happens you
know when you first look at the schedule
these they slightly pop out and you go I
miss boy we've seen about that kind of
thing I must always say you know you
almost forget where I was in the there's
once I mean there's so many brilliant
scenes in over 12 episodes and and one
for me that I just think your your
performance in is extraordinary Daisy is
is the kind of camera shoot in Stockholm
or in Sweden where ever you are in
Sweden which I just think is just who
it's so powerful really really really is
I think so yeah congratulations on I
mean on the whole thing but that's just
mind-blowing I think that performance in
that specific senior right listen we got
loads of questions that we coming in and
let's start at the top we got Molly
Jackson
do you all have a favorite part to shoot
or was there sequence that you find
really fun to create I loved there was a
few bits that are the scenes that I
absolutely loved that were really hard
to shoot so that they were you knew they
were good but they kind of were tough
and then there were once which were
great I'm love you to shoot oh I think I
loved shooting a lot of the stuff that I
mean all the stuff between Connell and
Mary and the intimate scenes as a scene
in Episode five where they talked to
each other very honestly and choices for
what he did to Mary Ann in school and
I've yeah that was very powerful that
day it felt like we'd really there's
something kind of just immediately
strong about that my love doing it and
also love doing some of the characters
around like group scenes with Connells
friends and then later with Marian's
friends in college because they're all
brilliant actors that are around guys
and lots of just great actors like
Sebastian de Souza who plays Gareth and
you know Fiona Shea and and shawn dunn
and Anna Hardwick and just brilliant and
you know just brilliant actors that
absolutely love and they were really fun
to shoot I love the scenes with you Paul
and say the green your mom and because
their jaw she's played yeah she's so
brilliant in the show and also just like
the best crack to have around on set
she gives you that hug Christmas yeah I
mean I know it's not you Daisy but it's
business money and that hug at the door
at Christmas for just a wee bit longer
than you know and it's just it says so
much and just that moment of intimacy
it's beautiful
Lorraine she's one of my favorite scenes
actually to watch ISM is the wonderful
scene between um Lorraine and Connor in
the car when she kind of she gets out I
just think is you know you're like a
idiot Colonel what we go here and show
on Hugh says Lennie can you speak to
issue of keeping a consistent style and
tone across the seas with two different
directors and did you have a lot of
input as an exec on episodes you didn't
direct I mean I think a lot of my input
was a reserve script stage so and that
was obviously all the way through just
working closely with the team and and
making sure that the like with everybody
else that the story was kind of woven um
I suppose consistently through all the
episodes and um but actually with
somebody as experienced and gracious
Hetty I think once I'd said up what I'd
set up I knew that she wouldn't do
anything that would break that you know
and she was what we did do was we
chatted at the very beginning and then I
made all the rushes and assemblies and
cuts that we had available
it's add he said that she could see what
we were doing but it wasn't like a
question of of me sort of overseeing her
and in any way because she's you know we
wanted her to feel that she could also
bring her and her kind of visual stories
having intelligence to her episodes
mm-hmm but I think it is it is a
testament to the overall structure that
everything I feel those flow pretty
seamlessly through the through the 12
episodes and Natalie open says Paul what
was it like moving from an almost purely
theatre background to a TV show
especially one that uses a lot of
close-ups and how different did it feel
as an actor I'm I suppose the the whole
process does feel very different in the
sense that like the cameras is very
intimately positioned through it through
a show like this and especially the
style of the show but I I I wouldn't say
that I Mudgett like i modulated anything
in terms of my thought process and I'm
acting I think if I was to go on stage
tomorrow I would still approach the part
in the same way and obviously I was like
I had to learn very quickly and I was in
great company to learn but like
people are got you you're gonna get
great feedback and that's kind of how I
learned that I didn't kind of approach
with any kind of preconception of what
it was because I didn't really have a
clue other than to listen and try and
play the character as I would say
regardless of the medium I think I also
say that when Paul when I saw Paul's for
a self tape which was very early in the
casting process it was like exactly what
you're watching on screen there was
harmony like no sort of item feel oh you
know he's great actor but we've got to
knock the theatrical corners off more I
[Laughter]
love this question I wish they put a
name on it it says how many rocket
isalways did you watch that I would
because you put it down and it's
definitely gonna melt Oliver who's gonna
tell you that I love that scene I think
this is well the other thing when you
watch it you there's so many moments of
that that you relate to you know in
terms of that kind of coming of age
falling in love all that kind of thing
there's so many beautiful moments that
you go I just added you know that you
you really sometimes like a mirror
sometimes in some of those moments and
David Mari says the soundtrack is
excellent yes it is and Steven Rennicks
as well with his fabulous score and some
classics and some great up-and-coming
artists artists like Yankee and Alex
Gough just wondering and did you guys
have much influence on the songs
featured um well the people so we worked
with two um great music supervisors
Juliette Morton and Maggie Phillips and
myself and somebody I want to give her a
huge like hooray to is nathan nugent
who's the editor that I've worked with
for many years and is very very good
musically so between Nathan myself
Stephen the two music supervisors
that's where um Stephens soundtrack and
the the licensed tracks came from and um
I was listening you know just listening
as widely as I could and actually was
just struck by how many it wasn't
something you started off by saying
let's have loads and loads of Irish
artists but actually they just felt
right like em Regan and um you know
Orla Gartland and lisa hannigan and
people like that they just all felt like
they were part of the world and then you
know so there were a lot of Irish
artists in it and then like Nathan's
idea was was making his idea to use an
80s racket or a nineties it track the
Yazoo track at the end of episode 3 and
you know so we all had and I'm a big
Elliott Smith fan and that's where that
track came from a man Juliet and Maggie
came and stuff as well so it was and
everybody was throwing ideas in did you
guys create playlists at all for the
characters did you is that something you
talked about kind of first were talking
about when we were in rehearsals a lot
when we were like at that stage where
we're very polite with each other just
before we started filming we would just
talk about sort of music really because
I'm Paul had found Sally green II had
written a playlist for the characters
and so he found it on Spotify so we were
kind of yeah listening to that load did
you play on sec mmm
playing like them the makeup trailer
beforehand and yeah I did I kind of
didn't know like Spotify stock of Sally
really because I've heard of risers like
making playlists as their writing and I
I found she had a separate one for
Marianas everyone for Carmel and that I
think I'm nearly sure that she wrote her
and she made during the writing process
so that was kind of a bit of a golden
find what is it what is it dear how does
it help
I find that music gives you a kind of
very quick access into a particular
emotion or something at the distinct
personalities of both uh Sally's
playlist deafened
give you a flavor of there both of their
identities and I just find it gives you
kind of access to different kind of
emotions I think yeah and Neal Bradley
says lady when you were prepping the
shoulder Joon Suzy and shoot test
sequences to develop the look your
visual approach to the CDs yeah we did
so we shot I think we had a day and a
half kind of testing where we were you
know we tried different lenses we had a
pretty strong idea of what what we were
going to shoot the show on of these
beautiful old lenses called k35 but we
tested those and we tested also the
process afterwards like what kind of
look we would give the rushes which is
kind of an important choice because even
though the very nerdy now but all the
digital media is still there untouched
underneath just choosing a look for it
as you shoot it's kind of important and
so we went through a process and we try
different tried out different ins we
camera tested the lenses on the guys and
we also looked at wardrobe and and
design ideas through the lens and I
didn't post so that we could just be
sure that we were we're getting what we
wanted to get and based on somebody else
asked me about references and I said I
answer the question on context there but
yeah just sort of comparing what we
thought things would look like with how
they were actually looking and it always
teaches you something but actually into
the first few days of shooting your I
think are often those days are also
about refining the ideas as you start to
see what scenes look like cut together
and and all that kind of stuff well
where are your references do you mind me
asking and did you share those with with
Daisy and and Paul as well in terms of
well what was one brilliant thing was
one of the photographer's that we used
as a reference guy called Enda Bo he's
an Irish photographer was shot a lot in
London and fine art photographer M and
so happens that I met ender like after
he liked a film we made years ago we
became friends and actually he agreed to
be our on set photographer so one of our
references was the guy who was sitting
by the camera with his stills and then
and
references look and see where I answer
this and because yeah we looked nan
goldin
amazing photographer of herself and sort
of quite a lot of nudes and pictures
with lovers we felt we're really moving
and incredibly candid without feeling
like they were exploitative or or you
know in any other way sensationalistic
and she was a reference and a really
interesting British film called witness
I think it's called witness which is
about Jehovah's Witnesses or mother and
daughter yeah which is really good and
we just loved the there are aspects of
the way that that approached character
that we really liked and but we also
watched em bits of I don't know school
stuff in in things like Gus Van Sant and
not necessarily to copy but just to get
a sense of what just to get herself
thinking and so yeah lots of photo
references it was it was that was that's
always a really nice part of the process
working with the cinematographer to
towards a look and this is there's kind
of two questions that cover a similar
thing one from poppy Clarke one from and
some and it's it's Daisy for you and in
pour about training and practice and
studies actors and and where did you
train and how did you get em you know
your agents and recognized yes so I I
was my mum told me to audition for the
National Youth Theatre when I was about
14 and and that was kind of my first in
to I guess a place that had lots of like
my from people who were the actors and
it was the first time I kind of and
realized that it could be a career
choice so I did shows with them every
year and then through them they have a
big open casting for films that you know
fact is you want represented so I went
up for an audition if I think it was a
little moment he does something venerate
the casting director of that and was
happened
my little boy trying again Sean you stay
here can show up sheesh
it was through that audition the casting
director knew my agent was looking for
and somebody from the National Youth
Theatre to work with so
I met with Chris and and yeah it was
through him that I kind of got my first
job so it was really the National Youth
Theatre that I everything to really firm
for getting me into the industry or what
about for you yes so I I suppose the
first point protocol would have been
that I did a School Musical when I was
16 and then loved it but didn't I just
didn't see it as a I didn't have any
reference point as other people I saw
being actors in like real big grown-up
life and but the closer I got to
applying for colleges the more I kind of
realized that that was the thing that
excited me most and something that I
could see spending time like sticking
out and and really enjoying so I applied
to the lyric Adam II in Dublin which is
the Drama School attached to Trinity and
trained there for three years and kind
of just thought that three the three
years he kind of Cocoon yourself in a
place where people just talk about
acting and writers and directors and it
was a really valuable time and I think
because I didn't really have a huge idea
about what it was before I had time to
kind of develop a taste and develop
preferences in terms of and what kind of
actor I wanted to be so that was kind of
how I got into it am i right in saying
this like Leah McNamara who plays Rachel
she would be layer as well and I don't
think Lee I think it might not be yeah
right
yeah he's and Mary Ann's brother eina
Clinton Megan Dona there's a lot there's
a Liam Lee representation in the show
which is great you can totally seize
well that's what's so subtle about um
you know finding out about Mariana and
kind of how she ticks and what and you
look into that family environment that
she's come from and the relationships or
that she does or doesn't have with her
brother and her mom and stuff is so so
important in to to to Harlan you know
how how she decides on certain
situations and how she reacts them as
well and it's amazing to kind of watch
those relationships kind of unfold and
see how important they are to to her as
well
and some couple of more questions coming
in and just on the back of that one as
well just on you know in terms of train
and Emily see who I imagine must be a
young actor wants to get advice and what
would your advice be to you're not just
trying to break into TV film industry
Lenny this is a good one for you answer
as well I mean it's one of those it's so
I think everybody's got a different
story you know people who are acting on
screen like Daisy not having gone to
drama school and then I'm thinking of
Paul haven't gone ceramic scooter like
say those lovely scenes he played with
Elliot souls he plays um Joanna your
sort of best friend she's she's trained
and that's her Road in and you rode in
was different and I think um the most
important thing is to be doing it to
whatever level you can I mean so there's
no there's no sort of obvious people
somebody say we just have to keep
knocking on doors or hassling people or
hmm I don't know if that's always the
way to go I think trying to do good work
and challenge yourself and um you know
whatever that whatever level your art is
the only thing you can do I mean you
guys probably have there I've been stood
in the actors view on that as well
because you have so many friends who are
in and out of the screen side of things
yeah I think I think it's about for me
it's figuring out whether you're an
actor who would benefit from a
three-year training or whether you think
that that kind of institution could be
detrimental to your creativity and I
think that's something that you kinda
have to decide for yourself and I think
ultimately after that because I I
believe that you don't really have a
huge amount of control a lot of the time
in this industry it's about controlling
the things that you can do and if that's
preparation for auditions or if that's
reading scripts or watching films that
are being recommended there I think I
ball coach when I was growing up who
always said control the controllables
and you'll do OK and I think that's
that's really good advice and it's not
to get caught up with and gaming or
getting to a final destination with it
and that's a hard thing to put into
practice but I think
that would be my advice I think easy
what about you yeah I really couldn't
put it better than that I think that
there really is not much you just can
control you know and I think it's just
knowing that if you love it enough it
will work out and kind of yeah to
control the controllables that I mean I
really can't put it better than that you
find any way to do something but I mean
for me I guess that my real access was
the National Youth Theatre so I'd say
you know if you love it join a wonderful
youth company it's not only do you meet
um not only do you learn I guess you
know you train in some capacity but also
to kind of work work as a team is
something that's so important in
particularly I think for TV you know
you're just one cog in a whole picture
so I think being able to UM yeah to be
an ensemble so to speak and and to make
to meet friends who are like-minded and
in creating it's really wonderful so
yeah for me I guess new theatres as well
would be anything to do yeah and this is
a great question from Josh she says hi
lady and what was it like working with
Alice Brooke she's such an exciting play
right and exploring and playing with the
meaning of form and pieces like anatomy
of a suicide and a wireless is know very
familiar to TV but did that translate to
the process it was infectious yes yes is
you know we were really really lucky
that Alice a was such a fan of book and
B was prepared even though she
officially didn't even she didn't have
the time and she was she's so she's so
in demand and she's doing her own plays
and also working in other projects for
the screen so it just it was a wonderful
thing to to get her on board it was
yeah she's such a she's a wonderfully
collaborative person and um just an
incredibly intuitive writer and she also
has this ability she has her very much
her own voice as a playwright but she
can also she's bright enough and
sensitive enough to sort of feel her way
into somebody else's voice and she
really got Sally's voice I think you
know and and it's it's hard to see
unless you know the book very well I
think it's hard to see where um things
have been added or shifted or reimagine
in the adaptation because
it's done so skillfully by Allah such
that it becomes kind of it feels like
it's always been there um yeah I loved
working with her and I would love to do
it again and and we only got we got to
spend some time together and all of us
you know she we would do these sessions
were where she'd come over or we go over
to London and and but we did a lot like
this you know before we had to before
locked and we did a lot of sort of
skyping and zooming and I feel she was
just this massive asset to the show
there's a couple of them isolation
questions actually which are slightly
random but interesting Claudia says have
you found the release of the show
different in isolation you know it's
funny actually I mean Paul and I would
talk about this earlier about how um I
think actually weirdly it's it's a
really perfect time for it going out
because the story is so about the
essence of a human relationship and how
important that is and I think that's
something we're all kind of craving
right now so you know again yeah I would
say it it does feel so I guess more
poignant really during this kind of
climate this is the first show like
being in four so far to come it is the
normal anything else will be abnormal to
me so I don't really have anything else
to go off to measure of it I mean well
taking that into mind you know in terms
of this is the first TV thing that
you've worked on and the response that
it's hard you know this was a huge book
and and I don't know if any of you felt
under pressure with regards to you know
people's I guess love of this book and a
knowledge of this book and kind of gone
into that but from the reception that
it's hard considering its what it's not
even been available for 24 hours is it I
think this is extraordinary to kind of
just even from from someone from afar to
feel the wave of kind of just joy in the
in the series well how does that feel
for you guys it's I feel like it's an
immense relief and you know just because
when you a you I think we're all first
and foremost fans of the book so we want
that that applies its own pressure you
want to deliver and try to match the
book as best you can and
when you feel like you you're proud of
the work and then you're getting closer
and closer to transmission days you're
praying to the high heavens that people
like it and when you feel that wave of
like generosity and people talking
positively about it it's it's relief and
joy and just like feels like this and
adrenalin just leaves your body because
they're building up for like months and
months so it's it's it's a great feeling
I think yeah yeah it's sort of hard to
even and yeah imagine it really because
you know it's all kind of happening on
our phones you know cause it's a bit
strange but yeah I'm just so relieved
that you know that because I love it and
we had such a wonderful time making it
and I'm so proud of it so I'm just glad
that everyone else also you know
connects with it yeah immensely relieved
daddy what about phew
same as as the other guys I mean I think
like I've been around obviously for a
while and you have the experiences of
things that you care really deeply about
sort of entering the world without much
of a response you know and it's a bit
like you come flying out of the out of
the velvet curtains and there's like two
people and it's all kind of you know you
fee you've sweated blood over this for
years so I think it's important to
really enjoy the times where it actually
connects and of course like I don't know
it's so odd because as Daisy was saying
it's all in your phone and realist that
and you think maybe this is just a
bubble of people who decide to comment
and but it does feel genuinely like
there is a sense that there is something
lovely about this and that I'm not as
good and the work is good and we we felt
that and I suppose that worry when
you're making something that and
television is so there's so much out
there you know there's just such a vast
amount to watch yeah maybe even though
we knew that this was good and and and
that we put our heart into it there's
the worry that it will just sort of
drift away
there are nobody much will pay attention
to it and it's relieving and should be
celebrated I think that it could've
husband or seemed still found an
audience and a couple of quick things
before we finish off and this is kind of
I think a really nice question that
Palmer ensign and because you know one
of many things that you do consistently
work with with every project they
involved in Lennie is you just get these
extraordinary performances from people
you know be that you know room Frank
this it's just them and Paul says did
you ever study acting you know in any
ways in order to understand the theory
and practices behind working with actor
it's a great question um I read like
I've always been fascinated by actors
I'm fascinated by that that it's the
same way I'm fascinated by people who
were incredibly musical and have
disability - I don't know both do
something highly technical but make it
fluent and so I've always been
fascinated and of course about it a lot
my did in college activist and I was
like okay but I was kind of more
interested in us watching it and
thinking about it and um and sort of
that's obviously what the director does
he kind of try and provide some it's a
it's a process of feeding back and
helping and kind of revealing for the
actor something that they've already got
inside them and and I read a lot about I
always read you know old like all of the
classic texts on acting and on theatre
and then the one thing I did which is
had a big effect on me a very wonderful
Michael Lawrence Brown in Ireland who is
a bel canto teacher um and I took
lessons with him and and read a lot
about bel canto and there's a lot in the
in the idea of what is authentic in
performance in singing from a tradition
that I took with me into working with
actors it's not something I've ever
really actually spoken about very much
but but that was something that was
quite fundamental to how I thought about
and how I might work with actors when I
eventually started to do it and I said
re acity what would be in that because
I've never even spoken to your aircraft
and I it's just about it's a sort of
idea of what it is to sort of present to
authentically present an action or and
singing is this very
thing where if the singer is in any way
sort of false or kind of caught up it
just doesn't come out very well and I
mean it's it's probably something for a
longer in a different context but when
we can have a beer together again Ida to
talk to you about it I just quite like
to do cardio okay with you if that's
your kind of rock singer kind of like
and Lords of people this is kind of nice
in terms of body harnesses where do you
think the characters end up and an
anonymous attendee says pawn Daisy how
do you think Connor and Mariana do in
post episode 12 I mean III quite love
that you know I think that's why I love
the ending so much is that they're still
very much alive which is really
absolutely breathing and navigating the
world but I mean I think that they're I
hope that Conell is flourishing in New
York and and you know really pursuing
history even and being very successful
and I hope Mariana is very settled she
probably doesn't have a job for you she
doesn't believe in the capitalist system
I hope that she's you know aces her
degree and yeah I think she'll probably
go and stay with Lorraine for a bit I'd
say she's probably with snoring he said
I love the idea and listen there's been
a lovely and someone just sent in a
really lovely message which I was tryna
I'm trying to read all these live
questions as they come in and it was
someone just saying thank you so much
for creating such an honest and
brilliant experience to watch and making
such a great adaptation of a book like
absolutely love so that's I guess the
highest praise is it you guys can get
but also just they the overall response
to this has just been extraordinary and
thank you so much for sparing the time
to come and chat to us tonight it's been
an absolute treat thank you guys thank
you very much really enjoy thanks Edith
and thanks everybody for tuning in take
care don't forget it's on BBC one nine
o'clock tonight episodes 1 and soon
everything all the others are on every
all of them are on iPlayer to go and
binge and watch take care guys thank you
so much bye
[Music]
[Music]
you